- First the material is leather.
- Okay.
- And the black on is for night,
and in the morning it's very hot,
- Understood.
- and it's very brown.
- Okay.
Okay.
- So the --
- When students are doing client
projects, their engagement
and their sense of
ownership is at its peak.
And the learning that takes place during
that time
is very rich.
- The material you said
was leather, right?
- Yeah.
- Do you wear leather in the summer?
Don't you think it would get a bit heavy?
- The whole idea behind the school
is the child is the stakeholder.
We want every child
to believe that I can do
what I want to do.
And I can be the person I want to be.
- We have never learnt to
give up in this school.
It's all about, "I can."
- Client projects
is a wonderful process at Riverside,
and it takes place across all the grades.
It's a very important way for children
to understand the relevance
of what they're learning.
The client is from the real world.
Different people and
different professions.
The teachers first meet the client
to understand the client's need.
Then with the client
you co-create what is an end result
that you want from the children.
- The client gives you a project to do
and then you have to work on it.
You feel it so real.
We like having challenges and all.
- Before any client project,
we look at the content
we are going to cover in
the particular classroom.
Our unit was adaptation.
They're learning basically
about different habitats
and which animals survive there.
When we looked at this
kind of program of inquiry
we thought of ,
who can be a client for us?
- Good morning Riverside.
- [Children] Good morning.
- [Teacher] Do you all remember him?
- [Children] Yes.
- [Teacher] Who is he?
- [Children] Captain Ayush.
- (laughs)
- [Teacher] Okay.
- Our client is Captain Ayush.
And our client project is
to make a uniform
one for the desert
and one for the mountains.
- [Captain] I'm open to ideas
that is what I have come to you all for.
- [Teacher] Okay.
- [Captain] Okay.
Good luck.
- Yesterday we were doing our first draft
- [Teacher] This is a picture of?
- [Children] Desert.
- [Teacher] Desert.
So, desert is?
Sandy.
- [Child] Sandy.
- [Teacher] Desert is hot.
- We really looked at when you
were designing the uniform.
The color has to camouflage
with the back ground.
But along with that,
the feel of the material
is equally important.
- So then,
there was a snow group
and a desert group. And
the snow group had to put
some cotton for the background
and the desert group put some sand
to make a habitat.
- [Teacher] Take it like this.
- And then we are to choose a material.
There was fur,
There was synthetic.
- [Teacher] Touch the particular fabric
and decide is it good for desert or no.
And if it is good for desert
why? You need to give
me the reasons for it.
Okay?
- So like,
I chose leather for the shoes
because leather cannot get torn easily.
And I chose wool for the T-shirt
and pants
because wool works in hot and cold also.
- [Teacher] Okay.
Aleya is gonna make a
uniform which can be used
- [Aleya] Both this side.
- [Teacher] This side
they wear it at night,
and this side they wear it at?
- [Aleya] Morning.
- [Teacher] We'll
definitely share this idea
with our client.
- So once we were done
with our first draft,
kids already knew we need to meet client,
get the feedback.
- [Teacher] We are gonna come one by one
and share our idea with him.
Prathma.
- He had selected few drafts,
one of which was mine.
He liked the material
but not the shoes.
- [Prathma] I used rubber boots
because the snow can be a little like,
watery
so then you don't feel cold.
- [Captain] Mm. How will
you water-proof the rubber?
Because if water gets into rubber
then that is a big problem.
- What I really see is
when the person from real life
comes to meet them,
they took it positively.
We are working for you,
you have to use it
and you have to feel comfortable.
So whatever you will say,
we take it.
- Doesn't matter if we are wrong,
we just keep trying.
We're gonna keep trying until the client
tell its perfect.
- [Captain] Bye.
Good luck and,
work.
You're doing really well.
You all can do much better.
I like it. Okay?
- [Teacher] Thank you so much.
- [Captain] Chalo.
- [Teacher] Thank you.
- [Captain] Bye bye.
- Once he is agreeing to the design,
we are going to stitch
one adult size uniform,
saying that this is what it looks like
and feels like
and then giving it to the client.
- So when you have a client project,
there are a lot of skills
that children build.
One is the content skills,
but it's also collaboration
that takes place.
The problem-solving that gets done.
Children learn to take
and give constructive feedback.
So all of these are things
that prepare them for life.
- And when they drive something
there's 100% engagement,
100% efforts by kids.
We are using their strategies
in a real life.
They will never forget it.
(child talking)